immer öfter werden brutale
streitigkeiten an öffentlichen orten
ausgetragen ohne rücksicht auf
unbeteiligte person schüsse in einer
shisha bar in hamburg ein mann wird
ermordet soll eine gezielte hinrichtung
gewesen sein
blaulicht spürende spurensicherung
mordanschlag in einer hamburger shisha
bar
mittwochabend 23 5 stadtteil hohenfelde
zwei maskierte männer stürmen in die
shisha bahn ist es auf der lübecker
straße in der bar zog einer der männer
seine waffe und feuerte mehrere male auf
einen 27 jährigen mann
die polizei ist unmittelbar mit einem
großaufgebot vor ort die ermittler
sperrten den tatort weiträumig ab suchen
nach spuren befragen zeugen
währenddessen kämpfen die rettungskräfte
und das leben des opfers doch jede hilfe
kommt zu spät die schutz verletzungen
sind zu schwer der 27-jährige mann
stirbt wenig später im krankenhaus
eine vermeintliche hinrichtung an einem
öffentlichen ort neben unbeteiligten
personen eine kaltblütige tat und leider
kein einzelfall
dabei immer wieder im fokus der
ermittler kriminelle großfamilien
duisburg nordrhein-westfalen vierter mai
bernd in duisburg auf belebten straßen
der feierabend beginnt eskaliert ein
streit zwischen hells angels rockern und
einer libanesischen großfamilie am
hamborner altmarkt
unbeteiligte passanten können sich
rechtzeitig in sicherheit bringen kommen
unverletzt davon die brutale bilanz der
auseinandersetzung 100 beteiligte
personen 28 schüsse und vier verletzte
inzwischen ermittelt die polizei gegen
insgesamt 49 personen teilweise mit
vorstrafenregister im zweistelligen
bereich der großteil der verdächtigen
männer aus dem clan milieu im gleichen
monat wieder ein clan mord in
deutschland diesmal auf einem berliner
volksfest
um 23 uhr eskaliert ein streit zwischen
mehreren personen aus zwei großfamilien
unter den streitenden ist auch die
25-jährige clan größe mohammed rabbi im
gefecht zog dieser seine waffe sein
gegner zieht ein messer und sticht auf
mohammed rabbi 1 der 25-jährige sagt
blutend zusammen und stirbt wenig später
bei dem messer mord soll es sich um
rache gehandelt haben mohammed rabbi
soll kurz zuvor ein mitglied aus einem
anderen clan schwer verletzt haben
mohammed rabbis beisetzung auf einem
berliner friedhof wird zum großereignis
tausende trauergäste bewacht von fast
200 polizisten unter den trauernden sind
klang größen wie arafat abou chaker sein
bruder nasa und klanglos ist
drei monate drei brutale
auseinandersetzungen zwei tote mehrere
verletzte die täter aus hamburg auf der
flucht sie entkommen nach den tödlichen
schüssen der motiv völlig unklar eine
mordkommission ermittelt und bittet um
mithilfe zeugen sollen sich bei der
polizei hamburg melden
[Musik]